in a Windswept graveyard Victoria Mourns
her husband
you are my life you're my heart my Heir
I love you she says
Ruslan was killed a few days ago when he
was hit by a tank round
his three-year-old twins still don't
understand their father is never coming
home
[Music]
um
telephone
Ukraine does not disclose figures for
its dead but it is a number that's
Rising fast
and so too is the rate of casualties
at this Rehabilitation Center soldiers
try to overcome their injuries
Oleg was lacerated by shrapnel and
doctors have warned him he may still
lose his limb
but despite his sacrifice he says
Russian aggression has only made this
nation stronger
foreign
Conquest has morphed into an exhausting
Jewel of artillery
with no end in sight
ing here in the donbass over the last
year has been absolutely Relentless and
it appears to be getting worse in the
face of a new Russian offensive now in
places like this
most people have left
and it's easy to understand why every
day now
the artillery is getting closer
in the shattered broken communities of
this region people are weary
shuffling through the cold to fetch Aid
Parcels as the fighting rages around
them is
no this is the vehicle yeah
but after a long year the cost of this
punishing war is increasingly only
measured in pain and suffering
and at the cemetery new plots are being
excavated for soldiers that have not yet
been killed in combat
it is a bleak picture and this of course
is just one military cemetery in a
country which is bleeding for its
survival
Alex Rossi Sky News in the donbass